after this lecture I hope you will have
understood how urban and spatial
planning can integrate ecosystem service
is an idea on how policy design can make
use of ecosystem service concept and
incorporate values and an overview of
useful approaches and tools and point
that's yeah I've been trying to make
over the whole series but would like to
again reinforce that monetary values are
but an input in a wider decision-making
process so very briefly objectives of
urban planning well obviously to provide
public services and infrastructure to
enhance citizens quality of life and to
foster economic growth what do ecosystem
services have to do with this well if
you look at these different topic areas
it's from most of them it's pretty
evident regarding ecosystem services and
environmental issues what can local
administrations what can open manager
actually do when they can act as a role
model in the sense of managing municipal
resources in an ecosystem service
conscious way they can promote and set
incentives for others to act in such a
way and they can regulate thus
obligating others to take certain
aspects into account we we think and I
think yeah from all looking at all the
different cases and and experiences that
we've analyzed that definitely there is
room to maneuver and that recognizing
ecosystem services by going through the
entire list is an important first step
to create the awareness and then the
conditions to make natural capital work
for local development and human boy
being we're actually missing the capital
in there we think it's decisive to adapt
appraisal design to your specific needs
and that's what you're supposed to do in
your project so that's very important
work before you get down to the actual
valuation but in order to get useful
results and I think that's that's an
important message to
convey to policymakers they need to
understand and be involved in deciding
on what is actually being measured
valued and how because otherwise these
values are just figures and they might
impress them for a moment but they won't
really talk to them I think that's an
important lesson for example from the
Cape Town study but they are plenty more
it's important to find the right place
for your results and decision making so
to quote one of parents favorite
sentences if economics is weaponry then
paying attention to rights and I mean
property rights and the broad sense that
we've discussed last time knowledge
relating to local knowledge and and
experience like for example in the
Tanzania case and participation of
communities but also of local
administration of you can get line
managers wonderful otherwise opt for the
people who directly work for them and
that that will help against backfiring I
think its decisive to build on the full
range of values there is a huge danger
and that's that's happening in many
places that single services are promoted
are developed at the expense of others
and at the risk of degrading the entire
system that doesn't mean you need to
calculate all the values and very much
in favor of prioritizing and selecting
the the ones that are decisive to your
decision problem but I think it's
important to look at all of them and
communicate the importance of all of
them
you